[Music]
Hi we arch
[Applause]
[Music]
These days, we're on tour.
So Run the World, I'm doing
well. I told them to show me, so I'm
doing well now. If the
kids don't do it in
Korea, then I do it in Philadelphia. It's a
very grown-up stir-fry
in the North Pole and
My friend likes it there.
Daniel Soyeon. What do you
believe?
I like showing my ass. Because my ass line is pretty. Actually, I'm
short, but
my feet are really small. My hands are really
big, so I think I'll
survive as a weapon with big, plump feet.
But I have to go as a person.  Teacher I have
stars in my eyes I
sat down after sleeping for 2 hours Liar I just
slept for 2 hours Bo-tae said I didn't sleep I
went three times
[Applause]
Because I'm
so curious whether Yuqi really did everything I talked about so far
What is he thinking?  I'm so curious,
so I'll tell you. Miyeon wants to live the life of a real princess. Yugi
is a public aspirant these
days. I'll go with a unicorn heart. Soyeon, why are you
like that? Did you do something wrong to me today?
[Music]
Hey, it was
made 5 years ago.
You gave it to me early. Soyeon.  Now, Olive,
I'll eat dinner at Neverland until the latest.
[Applause] I
ate something delicious.
This is Copy
Rabbit. I,
Fox,
Transformer,
Sleep
Hangout are
so good.
My uncle, You Who Came from the Star. Oh, that's enough.
Mix it up. Apply a lot and
go to Sephora with Shua for a day.  All day long, it seems like
I have the same personality. I'm the
same height as when I was young. I was
tall when I was young. I was the
tallest. Congratulations, congratulations. You were short, I was on the short
side. I feel like I'm growing up now.
Kids
inft enfp enfj intps
Then, we'll be
together for that month.  How many
people are born with the same date and zodiac sign for a month? It's
not a person, it's just a big frame or something.
[Applause]
[Music]